hi this is Matt Welch long with my
co-author Nick Gillespie of the
Declaration of Independence how
libertarian politics can fix what's
wrong with America which is newly on
paper book back we've been doing ask a
libertarian 2012 all day and thank you
to all of you for sending in your
hundreds of questions we've only been
able to get to I don't know about 25 of
them but hopefully you've had some fun I
want to shout out also to the Zoggs my
boys for playing all that great weird
surf music in the back and all the
reason TV crew for doing this we're
gonna wrap up here and talk a little bit
about what we have learned today from
our experience so Nick what have you
learned from doing out I you know I I
think this time around the thing that's
most interesting to me is that a lot of
the questions and not just the ones that
we discussed on camera but we're about
how do we apply the eyes these ideas how
do we get these ideas into more minds
and into more ways that people are
living in the world whether it's
politics whether it's culture you know
whether it is judicial strategies
whatnot and I do sense as we're in a
presidential election year people are
looking at how do you actually create a
libertarian world with more urgency that
knock on libertarians is always there a
crazy ragtag bunch of dreamers who are
you know smoking pot and playing with
their slide rules in their mother's
basement the world of libertarian ideas
is busting out all over the place
traditional political identities are
tired and exhausted people are looking
for new stuff and libertarians are
looking for ways to really put this
stuff out and road-tested as for moi I
think related to that interesting number
of questions including obviously many
that we didn't get to or people just
trying to libertarians trying to figure
out what to do or how to approach 2012
we had a fair amount of what the hell
was Rand Paul thinking type of questions
in an endorsing Mitt Romney is a vote
for Gary Johnson you know effectively a
vote for Barack Obama who's the next
rampal on it shows that the libertarian
vote out there or ethos is kind of
unsettled it doesn't know where it's
going to go
I think that is is showing up something
that we wrote a lot about in the book
independence as a block are larger than
ever America is getting more libertarian
than ever libertarians are getting more
independent than ever and those numbers
have incredible velocity to them I think
we can pause it libertarians are more
and more becoming a swing vote
independence will determine the election
in 2012 libertarians going to be part of
that conversation there's going to be a
competition for their affection and
votes and it's totally unclear to me
right now where that is going to end up
and I think that's going to make for a
very interesting year and so I've been
very good to talk to everybody you know
one of the other things we learned today
is that the Declaration of Independence
is going to be out very soon in
paperback it's got a new forward where
we tease out some of the the last year's
political developments and cultural
developments there's no question that
independence matter more libertarians
are more independent than more and
whatever you're doing whether you're you
know building a company or building a
private or public road or thinking about
who you're voting for don't don't give
it away cheap this is a great time to be
a libertarian and you get as much as you
can for being what you are
you